a show of respect for Ukraine's war dead
and a show of defiance to the Kremlin
the NATO Chief had previously kept his
distance since Russia launched its
full-scale War Ukraine is not a member
of the alliance yet and there was
concern his presence here might be
viewed as provocative no such caution
now Jen stoltenberg in Kiev greeted by
the president
his country is preparing to launch a big
counter-offensive and needs all the
support it can get
we do not know when this war will end
but we know that Russian aggression is a
toxic pattern that must be stopped let
me be clear
Ukraine's rightful place is in the Euro
Atlantic family
Ukraine's rightful place is in NATO
and over time our support will help you
make this possible welcome words for
this wartime leader but he'll want
actions too seriously we interpret this
first visit of the Secretary General
during the full-scale war as a sign that
the alliance is ready to start a new
chapter of ambitious decisions in
relations with Ukraine
it's a goal that will enrage Russia's
Vladimir Putin who's also becoming more
daring earlier this week apparently
visiting a part of Southern Ukraine
occupied by his troops back in Russia
the president praised those who've gone
to fight
they set an example of Devotion to the
motherland and its interests and now
they're standing for our historical
territories protecting people the
inhabitants of those territories
the NATO Chief was shown the reality of
this so-called protection the town of
butcher outside Kiev where dozens were
killed
now a place of reflection even as
Ukraine prepares for the next bloody
stage of this war debraham Sky News